if you want to know about why Mike was
the one to stay back in Derry while his
friends moved on without him then stick
around to the end of this video his
lesson is sponsored by expressvpn visit
expressvpn calm seas ease world to learn
how you can get three months free
[Music]
welcome to horror history who'd want a
history this toilet my name is Abraham
Lincoln taco hunter and this time I'm
not the only [ __ ] historian of this
episode because I'm covering Mike Hanlon
Mike was the seventh and final piece of
the losers Club a researcher who used
his knowledge to help guide his friends
in the right direction to be able to
understand and take down their
supernatural rival to understand why
Mike became interested in cataloging the
history of Derry we'll have to dig into
some history texts as well starting with
Mike's earliest days of infancy
[Applause]
Michael Hamlin became the only child of
William and Jessica Hamlin in 1946 and
was born into a life of farming one day
when Mike was only a baby the weather
outside was nice
so Jessica took her son's crib outside
so they could enjoy some sunshine where
baby Mike was attacked by a wild bird
which pecked at him until his mother
shooted away this trauma somehow stuck
with Mike into his older years where he
would continue to have a fear of birds
he drew up helping his father on the
farm which he was paid for and received
five percent stake in the business in
order for will to teach him the value of
hard work
the work consisted of picking peas
radishes beans potatoes pumpkins and
squash in 1951 Mike began school at the
niebolt Church Street School a religious
institution that kept him from meeting
many of the kids his age in town who
attended Derry Elementary leaving him to
fill the time his father gave him off of
work in the summers by himself the
Hanlan sometimes had trouble with their
racist neighbor butch Bowers and not
long before the spring of 1958 witch's
son Henry and joined in on the torment
when he killed the Hammonds dog mr.
chips by feeding him a poisoned burger
it was at this point when wil felt it
necessary to teach his son about some of
the evil people that inhabit Derry
explaining that butch was crazy and that
he should stay away from Henry he goes
on to explain some of the inexplicable
acts of racism throughout dairies
history will was somewhat of an amateur
historian himself and kept a photo album
that documented certain events from
dairies past he used this to teach a son
how to stay on guard and I think the
spike Mike's interest in studying the
past Mike also learned how to drive the
tractor from his father and each year
they would do a rock hard
although Mike enjoyed playing in the
snow during the winter he always felt a
sadness when the harvest season came to
an end will instill the strong sense of
morality into his son by giving him
small tasks to teach him life lessons or
take him on day trips like when he took
us out of the police station to see the
[ __ ] show a restraining device used
earlier in the century to punish
wrongdoers one day Mike discovers a note
from his father telling him to go check
out the remains of the old ironworks
that exploded in 1906 an activity meant
to clue Mike in on the violent patterns
of dairy's past this was only one day
after he had watched the movie rode on
with his dad and when he arrived at the
ruins he discovered a giant bird hiding
in the cellar hole Mike ran and the
birds swooped in to try to pick him up
so he took refuge in the smokestack the
bird tried to squeeze into the enclosure
with him and Mike was only able to drive
it away by throwing pieces of tile and
getting some assistance from some
unknown force helping him throw harder
likely its rival the turtle one of my
pieces of tile pierces the bird and it
disappears when Mike gets home his
father regrets telling him to go over
there without Mike even having shared
what had happened I think will is
somewhat privy to the effects of its
that haunt Derry and senses that the
ironworks could be dangerous even if he
wasn't aware of the monster itself in
the same way that might get a couple of
months later in June on the first day of
summer vacation Mike went over to base E
Park near the canal and smelled a salty
old sea smell in the morning fog that
gave him a sense of danger he discovered
a pocketknife with the initials EC in
the grass and he was gonna take it for
himself until he saw the blood this
makes him think of the bird from the
ironworks but he pushes that thought
away he follows a set of grooves in the
grass and they lead him to a bloody
piece of cloth and dried blood at the
canals edge he sees something move in
the outflow tunnel then hears a loud
splash that causes him to throw the
knife into the canal and run to his body
but he could hear what footsteps
following in the grass he would later
hear of the disappearance of a boy named
Edward Corcoran most likely connected to
the blade he found with the letters that
you see Mike was the biggest target of
the town's most prominent bully Henry
Bowers well I guess Ben was technically
the biggest target but Mike was Henry's
favorite target because of the rivalry
between their fathers in July of 1958
Henry and his gang were targeting Mike
on a regular basis on July 3rd they
chased after him while he was on his way
to a marching band rehearsal Mike played
the trombone and this would be the last
rehearsal before their Independence Day
performance the bullies chased him down
to the abandoned property at 29
niebolt Street and Henry reveals that he
was the one that killed Mike's dog
causing the Mike to snap and throw a
rock at Henry's forehead causing it to
bleed he climbs over the fence to escape
but Henry catches his shoe as he does so
Mike kicks down and breaks Henry's nose
the chase continues into the gravel pit
in the Barrens where Mike fortunately
runs into buildin bro Ben Hanscom
Beverly Marsh Eddy kasparek Richie
Tozier and Stan Harris an epic rock
fight ensues and the kids are able to
drive away Henry's gang the six of us
coach in the hospital that was the
moments that Mike Hanlon joined the
losers Club a name given to them by
Henry Bowers himself Mike kid relates to
these kids because just like he's
bullied by Henry for his skin color each
of them have something that caused Henry
and his gang to go after them bill had
his stutter Eddie his asthma then his
weights Beverly her scandalous
reputation Ritchie his glasses and Stan
his Torah the group got to know Mike but
they would not bring up their encounters
with Pennywise just yet and although the
movies don't cover it the next day Mike
would have his first encounter with it
in its favorite form one of Mike
Hammonds greatest strengths was his
ability to document everything that
occurred in dairy to use against
Pennywise now when I'm surfing the web I
don't want someone like Mike documenting
my activities online and using them
against me that's why I recommend
expressvpn
a VPN is a virtual private network if
you're connected to an unencrypted
Internet network without a VPN you're
putting yourself in danger any hacker on
the same network and steal your login
details credit card numbers really any
information that you send over that
network don't go out much
you still need a VPN in 2018 the FCC's
new rules reverse net neutrality so
these internet service providers who are
at least 10 times more evil than
Pennywise can now sell all of your data
to the highest bidder but not if you
have expressvpn expressvpn encrypts all
of your data and rewrites your
connection to one of their servers so
that your ISP and hackers can't see what
you're doing let me show you how to set
it up
that's it it also allows you to watch
your favorite horror movies that might
not be available in your country for
example I can't watch this movie in my
country so expressvpn is gonna tell the
website that I'm in a different country
and now I can watch it so take back your
internet privacy today because I'm
giving you three months free by clicking
the link in the description box that's
expressvpn calm /cz
to take back your privacy today and with
expressvpn
ah July 4th American Independence Day a
day for barbecues fireworks parades and
an ancient evil creature that feeds off
of children's fears okay who created
this holiday as Mike was marching for
the niebolt Church Street School bans
annual parade he noticed a clown handing
out balloons to children on the side of
the road and got a feeling from the
clown that reminded him of the giant
bird the clown made eye contact and
waved at my as if it had read his mind
Mike's trombone went silent as his mouth
dried up at this site somehow seeing the
clown felt even worse than seeing Henry
Bowers later on up the hill he came
across the clown again and wondered how
it was possible for it to have gotten
past the marching band that quickly this
time and many of the children are crying
and once again
Pennywise waved to Mike this is when he
recognized the creature from dearies
deep past in his father's photo album he
would share this discovery with his
friends two days later and the kids
would plan on how they could kill it for
the first time they also start
construction on a clubhouse in the
Barrens and the following week Mike
would bring the photo album along to
share what he knew with the others this
is basically Mike taking the role of
chief historian of the losers Club
perhaps the most important part any of
them would take on as Mike would soon
find out he shows them Pennywise cameos
in pictures dating back to the early
1700s then a 1945 photo comes to life
and Pennywise terrorizes them by
morphing into its many scary forms like
the werewolf leper mummy and dead boy in
late July the losers Club decides to try
conducting a smoke hole ceremony in
Indian ritual used to help tribesman
make big decisions by breathing in a lot
of smoke and having hallucinations of
the best path for do not try this at
home you'll just die or get cancer they
start a bonfire in the clubhouse and one
by one they jump out when it becomes too
hard to breathe leaving only Richie and
Mike they see the inside of the tiny
Clubhouse start to expand leaving them
in a huge space the size of a ballroom
smoke clouds their vision and they feel
themselves start to float up until Mike
realizes that they're no longer inside
the confines of the clubhouse but rather
outside in the Barrens although these
were not the Barrens as Richie and Mike
knew though these were the Barrens as
they looked millions of years ago
no standpipe no houses but lots more
animal wildlife such as bats jumping
fish and ant
the animals flee the area and they feel
as if they know what's about to happen
they can feel the presence of its and
drawing ever closer a burning object
pierces through the clouds and Mike and
Richard run forwards the next thing they
know they're being pulled out of the
clubhouse and out of the hallucination
by the other Ritchie passes out but upon
coming back to he and Mike tell the
story about how they were able to view
the arrival of its crash landing from
outer space I find it most fitting that
it was the group seer and the historian
who were there to witness and pass on
the story of this historical event the
plotting against it continues throughout
the month Mike joins the others in
visiting Eddie Cass back in the hospital
after his arm is broken and Mike again
experiences the dirty prejudices that
corrupts many citizens of Derry when
Eddie's mom gives him an especially
disdainful look while telling off the
six of them they go to the Barrens to
take turns practicing with the slingshot
to determine who would be the one to
wield it against the monster Mike holds
the best record by hitting a respectable
five out of ten cans until Beverly came
and slam dunked on all of them by
hitting each of the ten on July 23rd the
silver slugs that Beverly was to fire at
Pennywise were created and two days
later
seven of them turned up to 29 the bolt
straights to confront dates each of them
perceived the house differently based on
their own fears and for Mike it gives
him the same vibes that he felt that the
remains of the ironworks where he did
encounter the giant burger the losers
venture upstairs and come across three
doors
the first contains a mattress that
explodes and oozes out black liquid so
they shut that door and move on to the
second when Beverly gets close to it she
hears a scream coming from the other
side and it has a buzzing quality making
it sound like a giant insect thanks to
Mike's farming expertise due to the many
summers working for his father he's able
to determine that this is not a monster
but something known as a moose baller a
kin that lets out a constant audible
noise in order to scare crows away from
the crops the last door contains a
dilapidated bathroom where Beverly is
able to use the slingshot to drive it
down into the sewers setting up the
final confrontation of the summer that
would take place a couple weeks later on
August 10th Mike is riding his bike
through town and notices a strange lack
of activity and an ominous orange glow
setting over the sky some of the only
people that he bumps into are his
friends Bill is there with Stan Richie
and Eddie they cross over to the Barrens
side of Kansas Street where Ben and
Beverly run up to them going off about
how Henry Bowers had come after her for
her wife bill determines that Henry and
his goons are being driven by EDS and
decides that it's time to go after the
monster and once more they go
to the baron's and Iraq flies out of the
bushes and strikes Mike in the head it
had come from Henry with his goons belch
and Victor the move represents the
revenge on Mike for running to the
others and luring the bullies into the
rock fight where they were badly
bombarded with stones Mike retaliates by
throwing a piece of scrap wood back at
them before the losers all escape to the
sewers the bully's came down into the
sewers after them and Mike felt trapped
between his two worst demons as he heard
Henry's screams echoing off the pipes as
he continued to pursue them luckily for
him Henry would not catch up with him
for another 27 years but what awaited
Mike deeper under dairy was worse than
he could have ever imagined first he was
restrained by the tentacles of a giant
crawling eye creature that threatened to
crush him where he stood and left him
powerless to fight it it was only
Eddie's heroics that broke them free the
eye represented one of Ritchie's fears
but what would come was an incarnation
of something Mike had long been afraid
of this is another detail that really
cements Mike's position as the historian
and also sets him apart from any of the
others when it takes the form of one of
their fears it's usually something
recent that one of them saw and
frightened them for example Ritchie sees
a werewolf movie and it becomes a
werewolf shortly after to scare him one
possible exception is Stan the dead boys
he sees in his solo encounter with it
are from a news bite for many years ago
however he only found out about it
recently so it's still more of a recent
fear but the other exception is Mike
whose fear goes way back to a time that
he's hardly able to remember the bird
that attacked him in his crib is a baby
the next form that it takes is the giant
bird a form that shows Mike's eye for
all things past and present the bird
dives in and scratches Eddie and Mike
retaliates by slashing his buck knife
into its talons he tries to fight back
with the knife again but misses and gets
cut by the claws
luckily Stan is able to drive the
creature away with his knowledge of
birds likely saving the lives of Eddie
and Mike if not all of them and allowing
them to continue on into the lair event
after supporting bill in his
interdimensional mind battle with the
monster Mike and the others would escape
the sewers and vowed to take care of it
again if it had somehow survived Mike
involuntarily takes the position that
they would later refer to as manning the
lighthouse he stayed back in Derry to
keep an eye out for signs of its return
over the next 27 years
Mike was stuck with this because his
family was the only one that did not
move away but it's also fitting that he
be the one to stay for two reasons first
the others lose their memories of the
events of the summer of 1958 when they
leave and Mike must retain his memories
because he is and always has been the
bookkeeper it's his responsibility to
fill them in on the history of Derry and
the history of their own quarrels with
the monster when they returned second by
staying in Derry Mike is able to
continue to research Terry's dark past
and dig out the details necessary to
combat it should another confrontation
and be necessary before that happens
though Mike must face some of the
toughest years of his life in 1962 when
Mike was 15 years old his father was
hospitalized with cancer he would go and
visit his dad every day on his bike
because even four years after the
murders in Derry had ceased his mother
was still uncomfortable with him trying
to hitch a ride during one of these
visits will told his son the last story
he had yet to pass on the story of the
black spot fire in 1913 during wills
time in the army he helped open up a
nightclub that he and his friends would
be welcome jazz joint became pretty
popular and white troops started showing
up there as well until one night an evil
organization set fire to the place after
narrowly escaping will looked up and saw
the giant bird not flapping its wings
but floating with a red balloon tied to
each side this event suggests that it
has some kind of generational hold on
both hanlin's
and gives Mike confirmation that the
seemingly random acts of malice may all
go back to the monster still he couldn't
have known if it would reawaken again or
if he and his friends had actually
killed it in 58 so he continued to keep
an eye on his father would end up
passing away that year but he and his
mom would stay in Derry and Mike would
continue his education at Derry high
school where he became the running back
of the football team the former losers
club member didn't achieve the levels of
success that his friends did when they
grew up something that Mike atributes
for their triumph over its leading to
success in other endeavors but I think
it's interesting to note that Mike was
able to graduate from marching bands
trombonist to actually being on the
field during the football games
all of them kind of moved up in the
world after defeating ads at some point
Mike became the town librarian and
started to conduct deeper research about
the past of Derry in 1979 he must have
realized that he'd soon find out if it
would be reawakened because he
subscribed to newspapers in the six
cities his old friends now lived in in
order to keep tabs it was around 1980
that he started a sense that it would in
fact come back he claims the voice of
the turtle may have clued him in on this
also in 1980 he begins to work on a book
dairy in unauthorized town history by
Michael Hanlon he starts his research by
talking to a former dairy librarian a
man by the name of Albert Carson Carson
discourages him from digging in a
dairies past suggesting that the facts
that aren't recorded in dairies history
books may disturb him but Mike continues
depressed so Carson gives him a couple
of leads the man who poisoned his family
in 1851 the hacked-up Lumberjacks of
1879 and more gruesome details of the
ironworks explosion that he already knew
about he also learns that there was a
man named Branson Budinger who had tried
to write a similar piece to what Mike is
doing but is essentially driven mad and
died despite this Mike finds the bravery
to continue researching dairy and
becomes an important member of the
community over the years at some point
in the 80s the Aladdin theater where he
and the losers used to spend part of
their summers is in danger of being shut
down and Mike helped to call a town
meeting to save it despite the noble act
of saving a movie theater I think
getting involved in the business of
dairy was actually a mistake but I'll
come back to why I think that in a
little bit Mikey took a note when the
murders started up again in the year
1984 but didn't want to call the other
losers back to dairy until he was
absolutely sure that it was bad he got
really close to calling them in February
of 1985 when the disappearances of
Dennis Torrio and Lorraine winter Barger
took place Mike started paying off one
of the dairy police officers for more
information and copies of evidence
photos for his own documentation she's
gonna have a cow when he sees you nose
I won't tell if you don't in March he
stays late at the library one night and
finds a balloon tied to his reading lab
with a photo of him attached one drunken
night in April Mike reads about Claude
Hiro and the crimes that he committed in
1905 that night he also gets the sense
that it wants revenge for when the
losers nearly killed it as kids Mike
keeps done documenting the incidents
that take place through May 22 when a
fifth grader named Jerry Bellwood is
found alongside the words come home
printed on a cement wall in blood that
ends up being the final straw before
Mike calls his six childhood friends
back to Derry he sets up a reunion lunch
near the recently built mall at a
Chinese place called a jade of the
Orient his reason for choosing it is
that it's new and he probably knows
better than anyone that it has a
stranglehold on everything from dairies
past only five of them make its the
reunion and Mike has to explain how Stan
had passed away he fills them in on
everything I just said in the last four
to five minutes of this video that I
don't really care to repeat and as the
loser spend more time back in Derry
their childhood scars start to come back
and Mike reveals the cloth scars on his
chest that he would have acquired
against the giant bird in the sewers 27
years ago things start to get weird when
they all get their fortune cookies but
they try to play it cool when the
waitress comes by as not to raise alarm
so who do you thinks gonna win the
pennant bill asked Mike smiling insanely
Rose came through the curtain just then
her face politely questioning
I think the Chicago Bears look good Mike
said ahaha if only he had seen them on
Monday Night Football this week against
Washington Kaleo Matt Danny Trevathan ha
ha Clinton picked six no but the book
takes place in 1985 which of course is
the year that the Bears won the Super
Bowl the movie in Chapter two takes
place to 2016 so it would have been an
excellent opportunity to do the same
scene but with a different answer so
what do you thinks gonna win the pennant
I think the Chicago Cubs look good
anyway we're even was i right
Mike Hanlon they all go their separate
ways and plan to meet at the library
later and during this downtime and Mike
gets a call from bill asking if he can
store a bike that he just bought at
Mike's shed Mike somehow knows right
away that it's Bill's old bike silver
and says yes they fix up the bikes
together with a patch kit that Mike
bought a week beforehand on an impulse
even though he doesn't even own a bike
this is more evidence that there was a
helping hand at play this time just as
the turtle had helped them in 1958 there
was a different hand
fate guiding them as adults now when
Mike joined the group after the rock
fight 27 years ago he felt himself
become the final piece the wheel was
complete and it could begin to roll and
that's when they started making plans to
fight Pennywise the reason Mike had them
walk around town and regained their
memories was to see if they could close
that wheel again it would be smaller
without Stan but it was the only chance
they had defeat Ed's but that evening
Mike's plan would go horribly wrong
it was 11:15 a.m. after another meeting
with the losers at the dairy Public
Library when Mike advised them to all go
back to the hotel and get some sleep
he decided to stay a bit longer and
logged the night's events in his journal
but he had a strange feeling that he
wasn't alone in the library 15 minutes
later he hears a footstep and approaches
with a letter opener as his only defense
it was his old enemy Henry Bowers freed
from the mental asylum that he'd been
locked up in by it Henry has his old
blade back as well and the to go addict
it's eggs Henry on by taking the form of
Stan's head and then later belch his
head on the library circulation desk and
telling him to finish my Goff
ultimately Mike's letter opener is
enough to fend him off though and Henry
flees the library thinking that Mike had
lost enough blood to do him in but
pretty badly injured himself Mike is
barely able to make it to the phone to
call 9-1-1 Pennywise messes with him in
the process by taking over the telephone
line that mike is trying to talk on and
replacing the clock face with the face
of will Hamlet please find a Mike and
barely hanging on when they arrive and
transfer him to the hospital where it
would make one more attempt on his life
the other five decided that the longer
they waited to take on it the more
danger they were putting themselves in
for a long time it seems strange to me
that the novel is told from Mike's
perspective more than anyone else's but
he isn't there for the final
confrontation but on further examination
I think that's exactly the reason that
he couldn't be there for the final fight
remember earlier I mentioned Mike was
getting involved in the community to
save the theatre I think he basically
acclimated himself to Derry he stayed
there and became a part of the town and
as we know Pennywise rules all things
dairy he may have had good intentions
but he was really no more capable of
stopping hits than characters like
mister now and mister Gaudreau Mike's
days of the night in the hospital and
over the next four hours a huge storm
brews above
as his friends make their way towards
the lair of AIDS at 6:46 a.m. Mike
awakens with a bad feeling
it has possessed one of the nurses at
the hospital Marc Lamonica the brother
of one of the victims who has taken in
1958 he's planning on overdosing Mike
with a loaded syringe and Mike doesn't
have the physical strength to stop him
at that moment Bill and the others since
Mike is in danger they join hands and
telekinetically send some of their power
to him an instance of the losers Club
using the shine to aid their friend but
for some reason when the losers sense
that Mike is in danger it always reminds
me more of the destruction of Alderaan
in Star Wars
[Music]
I felt a great disturbance in the force
as if millions of voices suddenly cried
out in terror
I was suddenly silenced maybe we could
draw some comparisons to the abilities
held by the characters in King's writing
and the force but that sounds like a
fanfiction for another day the power of
his friends gives Mike the ability to
pick up a bottle and crack it over la
Monica's head bill and Richie had the
strength to continue on defeat Pennywise
knowing that their friend mike would be
okay Mike ended up spending the week in
the hospital on June 4th bill dropped by
to bring him his manuscript and he
offered up his place to Bill and his
wife who's trying to recover from her
encounter with its deadlines they are
all starting to lose their memories
again but this time and Mike is losing
his as well because with Pennywise dead
there's no reason he needs to hold on to
that trauma any longer he also feels
that with it gone and Derry is dying as
well which ties nicely into my theory
about Mike not joining him in the final
battle because he had become an integral
part of Derry by June eleventh the day
that Mike was discharged from the
hospital he had nearly completely
forgotten everything about his group of
friends from 1958 he tried writing
everything down the only logical
approach he could take being the group's
record keeper but the words faded from
the pages hours after he wrote them Mike
has grown tired of Derry and likely
moved on from it after the end of the
novel with him no longer needing to keep
watch but before he leaves he makes one
final dedication to the town that he
spent so much of his life in he
Commission's a memorial plaque at the
site that the standpipe once stood
before it was swept away in the terrible
storm to those lost in the storm may 31
1985 and to the children all the
children loved Bill Ben Bev Eddy Ritchie
Stan Mike the losers Club even after
moving on to a new life and finally
forgetting about the best friends of his
childhood he would sometimes still
encounter them in his dreams if you
can't hear my analysis of the other
members of the losers Club click that
playlist on the left and there are a
couple more coming soon so if you don't
want to miss out on those make sure you
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death Bell
or notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]